hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game but
the the game itself comes with some very
sad news uh on the 24th of august that
this year
wolfgang ulman died at the age of 85 and
we haven't uh
ran into him a lot on this channel but
we have uh ran into him
uh somewhat during the bobby fischer
saga we've mentioned that
bobby played against him in the 1970 uh
palma de mallorca interzonal tournament
and even though uh fisher was a machine
back then he you know obliterated
everyone
uh wolfgang ulman also did extremely
well
on this event uh and he qualified for
the candidates matches which uh he lost
to ben larson uh later on uh but
this was the the closest that wolfgang
ulman got
to becoming world champion in those days
but it was extremely hard
as you uh you can imagine the the
competition back then was was extremely
fierce
and also uh one thing i wanted you to
show is a
a photo uh where uh ulman is playing
against bobby fischer
uh it's not this game that we're going
to show this is actually from the 14th
ellipse
chess olympiad in leipzig the final
group a
in the final round 8th november 1960
it was the top board clash between east
germany and the united states
here uh uman uh faces young bobby
fischer fischer was around 17 years old
at the time
this was also in 1960 and it was one
year after the the great
candidates tournament of 1959 and uh of
course i don't have to
uh you know remind you the at the final
standings of the 1959 candidates
tournament those of you who are older
subscribers on the channel
uh most likely know this now why i've
chosen this game to show
as as a game uh to be remembered there
are a lot of great games from wolfgang
gulemon
uh but he was known to be one of the uh
well
most acknowledged uh leading experts on
the fringe of defense so that's why i
chose it he plays the french defense
here against
bobby fischer and well it is just a
beautiful game
i was drinking coffee in the morning
with yelena in the meadow
and a friend of mine sent me a facebook
post by emma sutowsky saying uh how
uh wolfgang woman died and you know it
was a really nice post i will put a link
to it in the description below if you
want to check it out
and he said what would be a nice game to
show and i said
this will be a nice game to show as he
faces uh well
none other than robert james fischer
with the black pieces playing the french
defense and it's quite a game
so without further ado uh let's check it
out and see what happens here
so the game was played in 1960 in the
buenos aires tournament
uh and uh well bobby fischer with the
white pieces opens with
e4 now we have e6 by woman d4 and
d5 sorry about that the french defense
is on the board with
knight to c3 and the bishop to b4 going
for the
uh for the winner variation of the
french and e5 by fischer
and now c5 is the most common move here
but uh
knights the e7 was played this is the
like the second most popular
option with a3 captures on c3b captures
and c5 so this is now perfectly
perfectly fine even for today's
standards
queen g4 usually what what people play
here knight to f3 also a possibility
h4h5
now in the days of alpha zero and lee
let's just zero
but also a for uh one one of the options
that is
very often played here making room for
the bishop on a3
to control this diagonal so we have
knight b to c6 adding
another attacker to the central squares
and knight f3 fischer
continues development and here bishop to
d7
uh here queen to a5 uh is the the most
uh often played move here
bishop to d7 and now queen to d2 by
fischer a very rare move
uh and here comes queen to a5 and now it
is as of move 9 that this position
was never reached again so fischer
continues development we have bishop to
d3
and now c4 usually not to be encouraged
to despawn
pawn push as it is a very very
anti-positional and now it's uh
well basically just why did that can
play on the on the king side but
sometimes uh this is this is a good idea
we have bishop
back to e2 by fischer and now ulman goes
for f6 so he closed up the center and
now he wants to attack it with f6 and
undermine the
the advanced e5 pawn bishop to a3
fischer gains control of this diagonal
hence the move a4 and now
knight the g6 remaneuvering the knight
putting more pressure on the e5 square
fisher castles king side and here uman
castles queen side and now we have
castles on opposite sides of the board
and uh well we'll see who's faster here
fischer immediately goes for bishop to
d6 doesn't allow king to b8 to be played
uh and here the the black king is very
vulnerable uh with
knight seat e7 by uman uh and
now what do you do here here is the
moment of uh
that you really need to be careful how
to how to go about the position with
white so
best for fischer is rook f2b1 next uh
well you can just double up here for
example rook b4 followed by rook a to b1
and put
a lot of pressure along this line maybe
in the future some rook captures and b7
ideas will be possible
all in all uh this this would be the way
to go but here fischer instead goes for
a nice tricky line he goes for knight to
h4
he wants to get this knight away from
the the defense of the e7 knight so he
can capture the knight with bishop
captures on e7
the problem with the disc plan is that
after ulman's uh very nice defensive
move rook beta e8 there is not much uh
for fischer's knight to do there so in
he doesn't feel like bringing it back he
doesn't feel like trading here
he instead just uh trades everything off
with knight captures on g6
h captures on g6 e captures on f6 and
the g captures on f6
so now fischer did some traits here but
all in all uh what he achieved is that
well he just gave black the uh semi-open
h file
and of course ulman will utilize this by
doubling up rooks here
on the h file well uh this bishop is no
longer
so nicely uh placed here on d6 as there
is no pawn on e5
to defend it so h3 by fischer and now
knights the f5 uh with h3 you gain some
more uh protection for the king also get
get a nice breeding square in and also
make an escape route for the bishop if
it's under attack which it is we have
knight to f5 by all month
and the fischer brings back the bishop
we have bishop to h2
uh don't hold it against me sometimes i
say bishop instead of fischer sometimes
i say
bishop's fischer sometimes you know i
have no idea why i do this
and here g5 so now you want to get the
knight away you want to start pushing
here and bust
open uh fischer's king side with f4 by
fischer with the idea that if pawn
captures you can maybe capture with the
queen put some pressure here
but it's very very unlikely because
ullman can just play e5 and he will have
this very amazing center here captures
captures for example the queen has to
move the g3 square covered by the knight
and the ones that once the queen moves
uh well
you can just bring the other rook into
the game and have a have a very nice
attacking game
so here instead after f4 we have knight
back to d6 now by playing f4 fischer
made sure that he no longer will ever
have a pawn on f3 so the e4 square
is reserved definitely for this knight
we have bishop to f3
fischer is ready for for the knight so
he can capture with the bishop
but now comes a very very nice move uh
basically the only move that gives black
the advantage
and the woman plays it with g4 and g4 is
such a nice move
uh because you're inviting the bishop to
capture the g4 pawn but if the bishop
captures then knight e4 comes in with an
attack on the queen and then the c3 pawn
and once the queen moves you can even
play f5 push the
bishop back let's say bishop f3 and now
this rook comes over to the g
file and now you can see that this
bishop isn't really doing anything this
bishop isn't really doing anything the
rooks are
well not doing all that much and it's
black will be attacking this game
probably you will have to eliminate this
knight but after that you don't really
have a
good way of activating your h2 bishop so
this is a really really bad bishop
so here after g4 fischer has to do
something but capturing with the bishop
well we've we've seen it doesn't do all
that much so h captures on g4 is played
and now f5 again gaining complete
control of the e4 square
allowing fischer to create a past g pawn
but now the h
file is open for uman to rookster to be
used so g5 fisher
creates a pass pawn and now rookie 7
preparing rook to h7 to you know wreak
havoc
along the h file we have bishop to g3
and now bishop to e8 uh by woman uh we
have
queen e3 now okay fischer has an escape
route for his king he doesn't have to
worry the c3 pawn is nicely defended
but not knight to e4 and that's just a
monster knight you have to eliminate
that because the there will be constant
pressure on c3 all of these squares are
covered by the knight
so fischer has to eliminate it with
bishop captures into d
captures on e4 we have king to f2 now
fischer
gets the king to a safer square and now
rook e to h7
preparing to at some point bring the
bring the rooks over to the
uh uh to the h file we have rook f2b1
finally now the the rooks come into play
but now
at some point you have to worry about if
ullman's queen moves maybe ideas like d5
will be possible
the opening up of the queen's attack to
the a7 pawn
so here queen to d5 a very nice
centralizing move by ulman
and now comes queen to c2 again you
could play something like rook to g1
just play a waiting move fischer could
also play a5 a6
try to create some weaknesses there but
fischer goes for queen to c1 he wants to
bring the queen into the attack
but the problem is uh now the the two
rooks
no longer control the h file and here we
have a most interesting move by ulman
rook the h1 and it seems like it's crazy
why would you give up two rooks for the
queen
uh and uh it just doesn't seem like
this should work however uh it
uh it does work and for a very specific
reason for example here
fischer should not give up the the queen
for two rooks he should play something
like queen e3
and then woman would decide whether he
wants to keep pushing with trades or he
can just go back and
say to fisher try to find a a different
idea
it's hard to say but if woman would
would feel comfortable pushing for more
here with the black pieces but i think
he would
and here instead of trying to
offer let's say a repetition with queen
to e3 fischer decides to give up the
queen for two rooks
but of course who wouldn't so rook
captures an h1
but not really uh feel free to pause the
video here and try to find what woman
had in mind while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on supporting uh
the
the greatest tuition two of all and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
the game it's uh e3 with check a nice
deflecting move that opens up
uh this e4 square for ulman's queen so
now
if you capture the pawn for example king
captures you're getting queenie for
check and now it doesn't matter where
the king goes the game is just over now
for example if king goes to d2
then it's the very nice uh rook captures
on h1 rook captures on h1 and now queen
captures sanji to check
either winning the rook if the king goes
to the to the back rank
or winning the bishop so it doesn't
really matter and it doesn't help if the
king doesn't go to d2 if you go to f2
it's even worse because now you just
trade captures captures
and now bishop to c6 and the only way to
defend here is to block it with
with either uh the g1 square or the h2
square for example rook h the g1
now comes queen captures on c2 check
king e3 you're gonna go queen d3
check king f2 uh and now queen to d to
check now the king has to go down the
board
king f1 and now finally bishop to e4
threatening checkmate with bishop to d3
not a lot you can do here so you can
make some room for the king
but now it doesn't help check with queen
captures on g2 king to e1 and now of
course queen captures on h1 you grab
both of the rooks and it's just game
over
so this is what woman had in mind when
he played this so after e3 check fischer
declines this
he says i don't want to allow queen e4
to come with check so he plays king to
g1
but now uh rook captures will be met by
king captures and the rooks are
uh stuck here so rook captures an h1
king captures and now not bishop to c6
threatening this because rook to g1
would actually help white but
instead e2 and this is now a monster
past pawn
uh fisher will not be able to reach it
because he has a dark square bishop the
pawn is on a light square and you can
only play rook to e1 but queen e4
defends it
uh very very easily so like i said if
rook to e1 you can play queen to e4
then this is this is pressure there's
not not much you can do
and if you try reaching it for example
king g1 to try and win the pawn then
bishop c6 just
again wins the game on the spot so
instead fischer tried something else
fisher
found a way to eliminate the pawn here
but he needs to give up the exchange so
here
fischer played rook to b5 now attacking
the queen
if the queen moves just rookie 5 will
then be enough to get the job done
so of course ullman has to capture it so
bishop captures we have pawn captures on
b5
and now queen captures on b5 and now
finally
rook to e1 fischer will win the pawn
but the problem for fischer is now
ullman has a past a pawn
and of course he starts uh pushing it
forward we have rook captures on e2
fischer finally eliminates the pawn
and now a4 we have rook captures on e6
and now a3 uh we have g6 fischer also
now starts pushing
his past pawn that famous g pawn
and queen to d7 now attacking the rook
and blocking the g7 square
rook the e5 preparing to bring the rook
behind the pass pawn and of course
ulman stops it with b6 b5 was also an
option as the queen nicely guards it
here but
uh you know why why push it all the way
when you don't have to
so bishop to h4 fischer now tries to
activate his bishop
but a2 we have rook to e1 you have to
guard the queening square there's no way
around it and the queen the g7 now
preparing to go after the pawn
rook to a1 and here um just captures on
g6 we have queen captures on g6
uh and it was in this position animal 42
that bobby fischer resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
once the rook once the pawn is captured
you're gonna go queen h5 put pressure on
the bishop defend and now let's say
queen f3 check let's say king moves
somewhere queen captures on c3
and black has too too much uh
too much material just the simple push
of this pawn will
will be enough to create a pass pawn and
win the game
so uh that's uh that's the game i hope
you enjoyed it the
the game i've chosen to to uh to show
uh and uh well like i said it it's
against bobby fischer and it's a very
strong bobby fisher this is already in
1960 bobby fischer so he he already was
in the 1959 candidates tournament so
this is quite an impressive victory
and although uh similar roshewski and
victor corson assured first place in
this buenos aires tournament of 1960
uh wolfgang ulmann by defeating bobby
fischer here uh
was half a point uh in in front of bobby
fischer
in the final standings of this 1960
buenos aires tournament
so yeah that's uh that's the game i do
hope you enjoyed it we can check out
this photo one more time like i said
it's not from this game but it is uh two
of them playing in the same year so
let's just enjoy that for a moment uh
and one other thing
one final thing for this uh video now i
found a a very nice
gif of ulman making a move so let's just
enjoy that
uh and then then be done with it
uh with the video uh so here you have it
there you go woman making his move
there we go very nicely done
so there you go i do hope you enjoyed
that and this uh this video
um what are you gonna do that's uh
that's
just how you know how life works uh and
yeah
uh we can check out some some other
games if if you guys would enjoy that
there are some very very nice games uh
if you want to check out the game
against fisher from the 1970 tournament
in palmade america we'll also link that
in the description below so do check it
out
uh and yeah i would like to thank robert
kretschmar and martin juba
thomas schleicher and steve boyer for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the good
stuff checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day